sweet
hello and welcome to lobbies GDC
sessions some special little podcast we
put together because the Game Developers
Conference is on just couple blocks away
and as a bunch of really interesting
developers and media people in town so
we said why not get a few of them in
here record some videos and also put
them on the lobby podcast feed so if you
listen to this thank you so much we've
got a bunch more these coming and if
you're watching make sure you subscribe
because we got two or three more of
these coming later in the week and I'm
very happy to be starting this off with
the man of the hour mr. Marchan Vince
key congratulations you must be sick of
winning Game of the Year awards The
Witcher 3 Wild Hunt wins yet another one
gin Dobrev atomic pies for battle
Saturday tissue podcast Benji Papa's
currency she is not supposed to go
yesterday Avenger from Australia yes I
don't know what is that yeah I I said
that today's focus will be fool in
Polish if you don't know if you don't
speak Polish yeah they'll not be a
translation but you see thank you very
much for having me here today
no thanks for coming in on such short
notice as well all I can say is set a
project red is that better
is that it was that pronounced right
Zack that work we could work on it yeah
to the Protectorate set up right said
the project set the project right oh it
so abbot added to the pro league all
right all right yeah couple of drinks in
me and myself okay okay congratulations
on winning yet another award what did it
feel like standing up there let's stop
here for a while that's another award a
game of the year the game developers
choice here in the US it's it's really
really very meaningful because um it's
you know among the top developers or
here and among the votes from the
development community we are getting the
game of the year so this is special this
is not just another word and we are very
very honored and very humbled and
actually last night during the ceremony
and I'd like it might not be us actually
for a moment I thought yeah her story
but there were not only so yeah they
didn't get it get that wrong last time
like at the game over it's a good only
five
I mean you won you know we'll get to the
sword game with the the GDC Awards a
second but you wouldn't game of the year
a lot of places during a Year award was
quite hard to win game of the year I
mean you had a metal gear solid game you
too for that game yeah you would rocket
League which a lot of people were very
very interested in that must make it
feel even better right it's great yeah
it's great
I'm always I like being on that stage
considering had you been on that GDC
stage before like not winning anything I
mean which one obviously not and which
it - um I don't remember it I think
we're not even nominated hmm so you've
come a long way and definitely that's
that's actually what I said during my
speech that in our case you had to make
three games we have to make three games
to to get onto this - and I was I was
thinking about the leap between those
The Witcher 3 Wild Hunt and specifically
with The Witcher witcher 2 which is you
what you've done something which I don't
think many studios have managed to do
which is you had this very you know
focused role-playing game with a big fan
base around it but you were still known
as like oh they're like that Koki
Europeans to do who kind of like makes
like this like really hardcore
traditional Opie or PG but in the space
of okay that's that's a good point of
view thing yeah but but that's actually
you're very right but look at your I
mean your market now at America is huge
like you've gone from - its number one
marketing right for us it's for the
percent or even a little bit above 40%
of our business but which I'm guessing
that wasn't with - right it definitely
wasn't but uh it's also it is partly due
to the game and maybe the fact that when
we released the PC version the immersion
group wasn't so smooth and I still
remember one of the really saying when
the editor who was a gamer named playing
games every day that he died 50 times in
the prologue so we probably made a
little bit too difficult but come on he
should have played an easy guys back
there but the the fact I mean the sort
of the main problem with going massive
in the US was the fact that we were PC
only right yeah so then
it is really tough it probably I know
five years earlier it would have been
easier but getting into retail getting
the appropriate budgets and I'm not
talking about gigantic marketing
spending but just just for people to
notice the game it is really tough
because I mean you guys sorry you guys
might like it so you might write about
it but still then the gamer is coming to
the store yeah prominently on gamestop
or going to Amazon or Best Buy and they
don't see the game it's somewhere on the
shelf and actually you know we're coming
here for years and I know it was
probably one of the most frustrating
part on my job like doing the store
checks and going to stories which are
which are W okay it's over here [ __ ]
very bottom we should have called it a
Witcher it would have been a bit better
but some you need us especially you need
to go with with a proper budget and then
in order to have this budget you have to
go multi-platform alright and you know I
mean the the PC gaming it's it's great
here but it's mostly digital so to make
the game visible and to go up against
the big guys so they don't know but
that's the release year Ubisoft you have
to be multi-platform and I think that
was the main problem with which to to in
terms of visibility and massiveness
particularly here in the US what was not
really the case in Europe I mean you
went eventually got witchetty on
consoles as well yes but then again it
was a year gap so you didn't have this
sort of joint marketing budget the fact
we Witcher 3 was first of all great game
big game but I'm coming at the same time
all three platforms so we could really
push it out there and then you know your
important game also if you look how how
the retailers look at it that's like a
it's just a PC game yeah and then it's
automatically different oh it's a
multi-platform it's is the big RPG and
against the poster yeah exactly exactly
people on the stores out how about it
yeah I mean now we're at the stage where
people you know presumably before would
have been like oh I want to play a role
playing game when they talk about like
Skyrim's and things like that no you
must go into a game start now and people
say oh have you heard of Witcher 3 Wild
Hunt yeah that's I think you know the
gamers do not realize it but it really
it really takes a lot of effort
- - to get to a situation to a position
where when you come to gamestop and say
hey can you recommend me a good RPG game
and and they say that's the Witcher guys
believe me it's it's not easy and it's
not cheap Eider yeah so but in those
like four or five years or however long
was you did end up turning what was like
those get like what you - is a fantastic
game and the people like I've reviewed
well and people who played it really
loved it but the the Delta the gap
between that and where you are now is
huge I think I think you are you're very
right in what you're saying and and then
okay so one thing was making a great
game and that's always the first and and
the odd most important thing like with
that but then getting it out there and
getting people to talk about it because
the perception for example of the Rito
was hey let's look how well did which to
salt and compare it to Skyrim okay
that's a small cookie hardcore game from
from somewhere in Europe from Russia
Thank You Danny yeah that's from Russia
somewhere around Russia you're about
right by the way what is Russia I people
call me Scottish all the time okay oh
you're Scottish on st. Patrick's Day oh
yes I know that but but uh but seriously
so I'm sort of making sure that people
commit to it and they want to put it out
there in front of the store that that
that was also that was also quite
challenging and and although we had I
mean great support from our partner year
Warner Brothers and and they have some
muscle that's also very important and
again it's probably not not the daily
concern of gamers but thanks to it we
are able to go wider and get more
recognition and visibility and then more
gamers because of that the ID game and
power to a certain extent because of
that again got even more popular so it's
like you know um like a domino effect
yeah yeah it's it's it's it's a domino
effect so this week's we surprised about
how successful the was or how well
received it was yes really yes I mean
you can never plan that you can never
expect that and and I don't think you
should because mmm if you plan that
something will be the best game in the
world and you will sell the most in the
world
you have an ego problem and so we always
try to be humble as much as we can and
humble I I don't mean humble not talking
that our game is going to be great but
we don't want to make assumptions yes
we'll rule the world
yeah and of course it's great in our
industry because you show the bits and
pieces so we talk to guys like you and
with a good critical opinion and then we
go to the to the trade shows period bd3
games come and whatnot and these are the
sort of early LD metrics was the hype
there did I like it I'm not sure if you
if you remember that every time I did
three we're handing you a questionnaire
and that's right about your opinion
we're really analyzing all this all
these votes very carefully thing like
they like this they don't like that
maybe we should tweak something we
should change something so it's a
constant iteration but then comes the
day one and and that's the moment of
truth ah yeah and then you saw was it
like four million copies in the first we
saw so we sold six million copies in the
first six weeks how much of that would
do this very particular question but do
you know how much of that was digital
against retail like uh if it totally
depends on the territory in the u.s.
yeah and it depends on the time of the
of the I mean in depends on the on the
precise moment because initially
especial out of the core audience is
getting digital here in the US so
outside in the US was was probably
initially 6040 forty percent being
digital so huge
yeah digital went really well and from
what we heard from the first parties
because I mean PC mostly was digital
obviously here in the US uh was that we
are one of the best cases and and I
think when one gamers planned approaches
these days they factor in a few things
so if they want to keep the game they
want to really own it and not just play
it and trade it back they go for digital
yeah if they think hey I'll just have
some fun for a moment I'll trade it back
I don't get some money back they go for
the for the retail
other people really wanted to honor
which I think it also shows how strong
the community is and I'm always very
grateful that yeah were you talking
about height before it definitely seemed
from at least our perspective that The
Witcher 3 over the course of like a long
period like three years was kind of like
ramping ramping ramping wrapping and
then going up you kind of seem to have
the opposite problem with cyberpunk
right where like you barely said
anything about it but people are like
are you suggesting a different curve
here but I people are like you've shown
what one trailer right like one really
good trailer yeah and I even feel like
when that trailer was shown people
probably didn't register whose CD
Projekt were four is now somebody sees
up and say said that project I read and
I got eyes which are three people the
right they'll be even more right right
now the the they see this trailer from a
totally different angle just like yeah
that's going to be real so thing I you
know honestly speaking again I really
want to be humble so right now we have
the success of The Witcher 3 people love
it people played it and and it's even
more responsibility and that's what we
had we had a conference last week
talking about our financial stuff and
our strategy and other mothers key said
that you know it's first of all I mean
the fact that which we performed so well
allows us to be even more ambitious with
cyberpunk but right now it's it's on our
shoulders to deliver here so yeah we
were the next time you will hear about
cyberpunk will show something and it
must be [ __ ] great
yeah what do you mean but like how can
you say more ambitious than which here I
mean which was like a like I was a
hundred and thirty hours when I finished
so which of which III was like you know
a tiny deal see you know even your DLCs
are big it seems like know there are
expansions yeah oh yeah sorry sorry
let's the DLCs are for free expansions
would you pay for yeah everyone can
follow suit that'll be great I but what
do you mean by bigger like what do you
mean buzz I'm sorry
come on we have the staff here we're not
talking about cyber bag I'm not I'm not
talking I'm not talking bigger it's I
think people really expect something
great and and that's what we have to
stand up to and and deliver so
that's so let's put a corner stop here
and let's continue our very interesting
conversation and last question and it's
not really a key to any is a it's a
studio excited about working on
cyberpunk yeah they definitely are
definitely big shift yes it must be
exciting it is super exciting it is
super exciting I don't forget you know
that we're working on it for quite some
time already so there's a lot of people
where you know maybe I don't know
drawing the the weapons or working the
medieval environment for years and
suddenly you know guns and ammo yeah and
mutants and implants that's cool like
something you're excited about as you
know I'm excited along excited a lot and
I'm just prepping my my Sarpong books
collection and and and I have I have a
solid plan of reading a lot of that like
especially my favorite so philip k dick
right now i'm into the demand from the
high castle because of the of the amazon
shells i I want to finish reading it
before I start watching the show but
yeah then then it's the whole cyberpunk
all over again
excellent and while we're on the topic
of putting quarks in conversations you
also mentioned like as another project
you might be working on as well did we
yeah apparently yeah and then this
project is a cork actually and we have
to put this cork where his place is it
are you releasing cuentas and so because
you said it's in a new genre as well
okay the the the name of the project is
project cork
so let's cork it here Danny the ester is
good it's really good
you're better that's tell them is there
how does it feel coming off this like
big game you worked on for four or five
years and then you're like because
you're an independent studio and you
know it's twas a 250 folks you have
working it warsaw uh-oh on the downside
it's over 300 or in total the group is
almost 500 is there a worry when you
like say okay we've got you know blood
wine so doesn't finish then you've got
like well but presumably it's like close
enough and then cyberpunk and in this
other project is that is that as big as
you want to go because like that seems
like a lot I think
as long as we feel and we can we can
unleash our creativity and we have
control over it I think we're good yeah
and and you will see when will shot
something yeah so you will be the judge
have you had people interested in like
you guys have been incredibly successful
and you're almost like very staunchly
independent have you had like people try
and come in and like yeah a queue of
them yeah yeah lining up in front of
those honestly speaking
what's up like that's normal I mean you
know it's funny I I remember when we are
in deep trouble it was probably 2008 was
to running the distribution businesses
that there was a big economical slow
down or even a crisis in European Union
so we had to restructure and at that
time mmm we're talking to a lot of
possible investors really needed some
capital to to finish off which to and
then we structure our distribution
businesses and those really nobody did
want it to work with us we ultimately
ended up with some entering this the
stock exchange getting the funding and
you know maintaining our independence
but it was a hard lesson and I learned
there really well that people are
offering you money when you really don't
need it all right and we really don't
need it only we don't want it we we will
never looking for for anybody from
outside to come and and enter ah the
company with with with funding because
we would have to give part of our
independence away and you know what
we're doing like for example we started
the discussion talking about going down
Turkey to retail and talking to them yes
so we're talking directly to retailers
of course you know we have a
distribution partners all around the
world but when we were hyping the game
we're talking about the game we want to
make sure that this is our energy this
is our message and before when on which
one when we had a publishing partner we
couldn't do that and it was so
frustrating and then what was delivered
to the market was not really truly ours
because I don't know we couldn't put
this in the box or do
with the box these are small things but
they matter and you remember probably
the the letter yeah oh yeah yeah yes so
sometimes things like that you cannot
imagine that how hard it is to convince
somebody else out there who think that
this letter doesn't make sense I'm not I
don't want to go into DDoS here but we
had a couple of discussions like that
yeah so on that that's also part of the
independence despite the fact that maybe
they'll think hey witcher 3 is to be
just cut it in half and you'll make more
money yeah or like why are you giving
away 25 piece of DLC yeah oh yeah yeah
that's perfect example come on we can we
can come up with a what a nice Excel
[ __ ] and what do you want so 2 million
dollars out of it I probably because we
could make it 10 in axel problem yeah
well what was it on the other side of
that sort of transaction now the DLC
yeah for the free DLC what was the the
onus behind it was was a goodwill mostly
yeah it was like respecting your fan
base and what's it like on the other
side of that transaction do you think
that people do you think it gave more
you know buying power to the consumer to
buy this game like they felt like was a
better deal or do you think they they
felt like they were taken care of like
is that something you do again like how
do you I thought that it was you
respected me as a consumer is what I
felt and I don't feel that way a lot
thank you then thank you sorry right
yeah but it's you know some people will
not notice it right people will feel
like you do some people will maybe not
trade their game back and some people
don't maybe talk to their friends and
tell them how cool it is when that
that's all it is
yeah um and I think that's great I had a
I had a discussion mom a month ago maybe
with one of the publishers I have a good
friend there and you know we have lunch
and they say wow margin it was such a
smart plan with this DLC see I said hey
but it wasn't fine it was only just I
mean of course we had to plan the
production but we just wanted to do this
it's a genuine move and so
we think it's a cool stander we would
like other people to do it but a lot of
people started analyzing like also from
a more financial perspective that they
did make sense but if if they do
something like that and even the
motivation is that just like I don't
know they'll put another two percent of
of additional sales in directories uncle
with that it's fine yeah just I would
like to see more more more things like
that happening I would like to see it in
other games as well but if they do it if
they do it for that reason they're sort
of missing the point as well right
because at the point wasn't about
finances but maybe don't understand yeah
one day and still gamers will get some
free DLCs and it would be cool yeah
it's kind of sad that that's like what
you did was something so outside of what
we're used to right yeah that's I don't
know I think it was it was in your
comment section and so release the
statement so saying that they're free
DLCs and one of the first comments was
one guy hey they must have ripped it out
from the game and right now they are
giving it for free just for the sake of
great PR and then I see some people
talking about it and then somebody said
man would why do you worry it's for free
yeah and this close the discussion but
was so beautiful so people are so
suspicious not because there are
suspicious by nature but because there
were so many different and strange and
maybe you know purely monetization
oriented tricks performed on them in the
past yeah that they are just hey
somebody's giving something for free it
smells it must be trick so no there was
no tricking I think we've proven that
with The Witcher 3 the other thing that
I feel like a lot of big publishers are
doing at the moment as well as trying to
create big online games where they suck
people back in and again and again and
then use that as a funnel to sell extra
content I mean like destiny is a pretty
good example of that you know but every
game seems very Ubisoft have basically
put online connectivity into every
single game they make regardless of
whether or not it should or not you guys
don't deal in
haughty fire it seems like anyway is it
is that intentional is there any sort of
do you feel like you know we do not do
multiple projects we do not release very
often so yes we're definitely interested
in extending the the time gamers are
spending in in our games and whether we
do it with the online functionality or
not we'll see us right now we did it
with Dex and don't forget that
ah is that this is the third installment
of the series and this is the first time
you're doing expansions alright yeah we
haven't done before just because we
didn't have resources for that so we're
doing expansions our way and if one day
we'll do online we'll do online our way
it will be different do you think then
like looking forward into you know if
you're talking about cyberpunk and your
your other projects is this the kind of
the end for The Witcher for a while then
like one spot in line is I definitely
definitely does that that's a closure
and you know I was asked about it before
they'll be with you for what not but
monkeys saying yeah we are we love the
world with huge fans of sub-code skis
writings but so yeah if something will
happen maybe somewhere down the line but
we don't have any anything planned
honestly speaking there is nothing we
are working on right now I think we need
to rest we spend the last word 14 years
yes world we love it but right now is
the cyberpunk time and we have really to
put everything we've got and then some
yeah and deliver here it's a little bit
sad to say goodbye to get all to know I
was crying she's before the interview
with you just just a little but it's
like it's your it's your magnum opus
right it's like you're standing on the
GDC stage because okay okay so let's
let's bring an example hmm you're
watching your favorite TV series and so
they tell you that it will land and it's
ending and it's kaboom it's it's great
ending it's really anything and you
understand that it's over and you accept
it and you have a closure and it's great
and so for me that's the preferred
scenario and in contrary you have the TV
series which goes on
and on and on and it's like you know
spaghetti-western going for ten years
and then at a certain time you drop out
and and you don't want to have anything
to do with that and I think we've seen
it with some games yes and Lee that's
yeah yeah for I mean I have any Call of
Duty's are we deepen or Assassin's Creed
you say the same thing as well so you
guys are like is that's important to you
to I guess have that really good IP that
the I things stay strong even if you're
not using it
yes of course and and so maybe maybe
we'll all come back maybe we'll tell
some different stories at some point but
right now really I think we with we've
promised cyberpunk
a long time ago and and right now is the
time to do some work here did you think
with your fans will play cyberpunk do
you think Ida fantasy so definitely I
definitely hope so yeah it's all about
telling great stories and and and
delivering great experiences yeah so I
don't think people are like I'm only
into fantasy RPG see if there's anything
else I will never touch it it's like wow
there's the cool game I mean a good
balance yeah yeah a good game will get
people to play like I remember oblivion
was a game that like there were friends
of mine you only play first-person
shooters but because it was a good game
like they never touched like that tolki
and [ __ ] but like they were also like
you know people who plays currently
probably don't play fallout yeah right
on that point actually last week in your
presentation you had a goal that was
that CD Projekt would be one of the
three biggest developers in the world
are you there I'm not sure how is it how
it was translated to English alright
I'll say that the one of the best three
best developers will be really I don't
want to use the scale because it's
meaningless what if we'll have a head
count of 10,000 and then we sort of
fulfill disco sorry yes I meant best in
quality not not in terms of size do you
think you're there I mean the awards
would say you're there at least in 25 I
really think we have we have something
more to proof how does this question
before and we actually had internally a
discussion who would think is the role
model for us and really when I look what
Rockstar right achieved
I'll laugh asked to be there and and
having the Witcher franchise it's
definitely not enough to try that with
her so I think let's let's wait and see
for cyberpunk and then we'll judge I did
are you more or less stressed now than
you were like ten years ago because
you've got I got decent bit of success
and money in the bank and but you seem
to still be setting these high goals for
yourself like as a company hmm actually
you know the level of stress ten years
ago which was was very different because
quite often we were fighting for
survival doing a lot of different things
and then you know like that mm-hmm
moving from the distribution business to
the games development I think that's
where we want to be we know right now
exactly what we want to do we want to
develop amazing storytelling experiences
and great games and deliver them
directly to gamers so that's also Juji
is part of it and i think the worst at
least for me it's when I struggled and I
wasn't sure what we should be doing so I
doing a lot of things and then you're
working this you know 14-hour days and
then you build something for a year or
two and then half of it falls apart and
then you restart you oh my god no no I
love the place where we are today and so
well well we are happy of course there
is there is a lot of I don't want to
call it stress I'll say maybe maybe
self-inflicted play pressure right yeah
but it but it's good that's that's what
motivates us and that's what will never
allow us to to be lazy because I mean we
are reaching high since the very
beginning of the company and and and and
right now we just have proves like these
are words that you mentioned at the very
beginning of our conversation that ah
that we are on the right path mmm did
those awards me a lotta the team back in
Warsaw along really you can't imagine
what was least pleased factor in that we
don't we're coming from Poland is I
don't want to say I don't want to sound
it we have complexes or anything like
that but
in a way we have more to prove yeah
because we're coming from a country
where you know games development didn't
have such a history wouldn't have access
to all these tools resources so
everything we were doing had to always
be way more global and way more thought
through reality an American company and
American developer could release a game
and if it was successful in the US like
yeah ok they're done and maybe you know
five years down the line on the next
game or the third game in a row they
would do some European localizations to
this strange languages and I want I
don't want to say that's the general
thinking but I've seen a lot of cases
like that but but the size of the market
was automatically mmm making it easier
for you to success just locally for poly
I would have never succeeded with
Witcher 1 just in Poland so initially
from the very beginning we said ok we
want our games to be played all around
the world and it was easier for us for
you in Europe and then us came with the
success in us came really commercial
success so with The Witcher 3 so we're
really happy with that and then like
this makes people proud and yesterday so
we go towards the game of the year and
the best technical the technology and
one of our guys actually one of the key
programmers use he was uh picking it up
and he's he said like [ __ ] I couldn't
believe uh we'll be better than dice hey
yeah this is the this is the real [ __ ]
yeah
people say our attack is better of
course it's it's it's an award you
cannot compare it these are different
things but but that's that's very very
personal yeah and all these awards are
very personal
especially after four or five years I'm
probably I'm probably doing that that is
not needed in this equation yes I didn't
know of the game you just got to sit
back and do business relations yeah I
just said all that some jokes about her
story yeah until look confused in the
back a shot at the game awards yet I am
so speaking about your competitors or
everything everyone else is out there if
there was like another franchise that
you
of to do to like to make to like
takeover production on like owned by
somebody else or diff'ent what would it
be I think and we had a lot of these
discussions but I think we have just
enough in our plate right now and so in
a world that cyberpunk doesn't exist and
the Wichita
no no I'll not answer it it's what we do
requires a hundred percent or actually
two hundred percent commitment so we are
not into buying and owning I piece just
for the for the sake of buying and
owning them we actually were approached
by a lot of people with really cool IPS
that we love to make a game but we said
hey if we do something we have to have
full creative control so we have to own
the IP but again for the sake of full
creative control yeah um so cyberpunk
was was a choice from the heart and I
think also it was good karma because we
just had a great opportunity to acquire
the rights but so I think we'll stop
here for a while
yeah do you think this will be like The
Witcher another 14 years you want to
build up grandeur yes exactly and you
know I'll give you the exactly these
dates Oh 77 78 79 I mean I might be
wrong by quarter or two but is that is
that a scary proposition though to like
take on something and then be like okay
like you're clearly or your methodology
the mentality you guys have is like
we're going to do this [ __ ] properly
we're going to take it seriously yeah
we're going to do something big yeah and
it's a new IP so it's new IP you need to
get at the gate yeah and we're committed
I'm going to commit it so we'll take as
much time as needed and we want to make
a huge that's so that that's that there
is more than what's on our mind and you
know I I I do business I do in
international development I talk to the
two media I took to gamers some our or
our phase in many many conversations and
I represent the company so of course
I had like hey this let's maybe acquire
this or Dan and we start discussing and
and we all come to the same conclusion
that if we invest into something and I'm
talking about investing our time we have
to focus because we cannot do it right
if we'll do even two or three things at
the same time it's just not possible and
and it's really regardless of how many
people you have on board it's a
mentality it's a mentality a little bit
look like at Rockstar white right why
there isn't a game every single year
yeah there is a reason for that so you
can have a different model B I don't
know if he for Motorola Call of Duty
Assassin's Creed model yeah but I don't
think it's our model yeah and what how
is it you're able to do that whereas
companies like Ubisoft or Activision
counts like what is it about your
presumably you have shareholders that
also wants to make sure you guys are
turning a profit what is it about that
that you know you guys aren't beholden
to that is it just your mentality we're
crazy yeah and we openly tell our
investors in um I'm you if you have seen
our our our mm conference hmm we took up
a lot about values about philosophy and
there is a reason for that and and of
and the fact that we are quality
obsessed and and it just we just want to
send a very clear message to our
investors that is not a short-term thing
it's not like hey expect amazing results
every single quarter and crazy growth we
think that if we concentrate and focus
and work really hard for for a longer
period of time the effects will be there
for them because they're also very
important for us ah but it's not hit and
run this is not like hey I'll making 100
percent upside in just two years no you
might not you might even lose some money
but if you if you believe in what we
believe in we shall if we share the same
belief in the same values you will get a
great return of your investment we have
proven that with The Witcher 3 so it is
a very different thinking to the usual
I'll see a stock market thinking but I
think it's right so we know that some
investors will never invest in us and
so and some investors will leave our
we're okay with that yeah and you're a
pretty strong position there presumably
as well coming off the back of that I
hope so what was your favorite part of
the Waltons cuz you were kind of like
like you said you weren't developing it
you were obviously like getting builds
of it as it was getting made but when
you finally sat down and played it what
was your nose on your favorite part I
mean I I actually I actually did all the
question marks in every one of them yeah
I mean probably have a couple left in
szeliga but I'll out say everything
about valent which is the bloody baron
and bottling yeah but but actually so
maybe I'll put it differently um what I
love about RPGs are re sub quests and
and and the freedom of exploration and
one of my favorite games is obviously
fallout 1 & 2 I love them I played them
a lot and even recently I started
playing Fallout 1 for a moment keep a
fallout 4 you know I was playing Fallout
1 I have it I have it on my list but hmm
good did this is the one difficulty I
have that it is a gigantic time
commitment and I know that if I start I
won't be able to stop and yeah what is
it about people making games that take
200 hours to complete nowadays [ __ ]
actually actually actually you're you're
laughing but I have three kids and right
and then I travel like crazy doing all
the stuff for the company so I really
have to play my gaming session right and
sometimes you know if I'm able to play a
couple hours a week it's a lot so in
order to finish Witcher 3 and finish it
with all the question marks andand all
the sub quests
I did it to my wife that I'll go for
summer holidays with the family and from
7 p.m. to whatever a.m. time I can play
and and actually this one I finished
which I really yeah when did you finish
it during the summer okay playthrough so
yeah yeah I what have you been playing
that since then ah it fits into those
little pockets of ties me I spend some
time with darkest dungeon and
I like this kind of I don't want to say
old school because it's not old school
but it's it's like true to the bone RPG
experience ah maybe a little bit too
punishing for me yeah to my life yeah
so that's I've been playing some Fire
Emblem I just I just got the new one and
yeah just about your 50s you said yeah I
bought my 50s because it's not that I
burned through them little quick but
when I'm annoyed with it um I'm a guy
I'm not a collector yeah the people are
always laughing that on my desk at work
I have nothing because I other sell
thing so I trow them away ah or I give
them away I don't like to have to no
good distributors yeah it's an even
birthday so what did the s is if it was
gathering dust because I didn't have
anything to play yeah I was asking my
friend to sell it on eBay so he solved
three or four of them and I just got the
fit because new fire emblem is a perfect
yeah that so I'm wondering but when he
will be selling this once per se I'm
losing a lot of money on each of them
probably like 80% Fairplay did you play
any of the other competitors last year
them you didn't play fallout 4 you said
did you buy back your solid rocket I I'm
not into the the sporty games at all and
so the last Metal Gear so it was on the
Gamecube I win snakes you buy yeah
really
yes yes that's the one I wasn't even
made by Kojima did the next one yeah
then the next one I have my lease is
definitely fallout 4 but but again it's
like The Witcher Factor it's it's it's a
bit spooky it's like who 100 hours yeah
Marcin do you have this time scaring
yeah definitely what I'm interested in
the mouse in in games like you know
personally as a gamer it's it's either
RPG experience or the storytelling or
ideally both sometimes even more the
storytelling so I and the perfect model
for me in terms of timing was the
telltale model right okay I really
enjoyed the walking that's the wolf
among us and I'm looking forward to the
next one I still haven't played the meet
young miniseries right the reviews are
like
you know mix so wincc yeah excellent
thank you so much
marcin thank you very much come again
really appreciate it at you've got a
talk on later today yeah it'll be open
to GDC for all our values actually so
alright I hope it will be interesting so
he just spoiled it all on this no but
you all release it later on won't you
yeah let's go please sorry actually yeah
I was just thinking was it Obama you
gave the me of which attorney was our
prime minister Prime Minister Prime
Minister don't escape gave President
Obama copy of what you take the
collector's edition and actually when
they called us means your foreign
affairs was trying to calling and the
reception thought it was a joke so they
actually contacted one of the big big
newspapers that we were working with and
in Poland and asked him to get in touch
with us yeah and we still thought it was
a joke but we gave them a version and
then you know on the TV in the evenings
but but you know but that's an old story
but then before right before a31 we
showed the which would be for the first
time was probably a week Obama was in
Poland right so that was his second
visit after the first one he got some
pretty good timing I have to say and
then so he's standing with Prime
Minister to scan his stunning his dog
thank you very much
Prime Minister for inviting me again and
lalalala and thank you for the gift I
got the the The Witcher 2 game which is
a symbol of Polish innovation we're
level yeah so tonight was amazing and
then you know quotes all over and you
know that's awesome yeah that's great so
would you give President Trump a copy of
Witcher 3 will see that we'll see that
if if this will be the case let's let's
let's worry next year you're not worried
um you know what maybe we are we have
some stuff going in Poland so you might
you might be hearing you know say we are
now we have we have our trump already so
actually a couple yeah I can appreciate
that
Marty Nowitzki thank you so much for
coming you Thank You rose it's a
pleasure thanks